>> Copenhagen was not as successful as we
all would have expected.
But it was substantive progress.
And remember, it's the first time where we
have commitments by the
United States, policy commitments by India
and by China.
Specific amendments by the EU in terms of
targets, a renewed strength
and commitment by Japan, and by large emerging
countries in Latin
America like Brazil, Mexico -- both have made
their own independent
commitments in targeting.
So there is a lot of progress.
What happened in Copenhagen is we picked up
part of these -- of these
advances.
We now have to move to a more specific, more
targeted and also more
binding type of agreement.
People expect it.
I think we're going to be working towards
that in COP 16 in Mexico.
But also from here to COP 16, it's almost
a year that we have to take
advantage of in order to deal both technicalities
as well as as the
matters of financing.
The whole deal can make or break in terms
of whether there is a viable
financing package there are ways in which
one can put a viable
financing package together.
There is the political will, there is the
awareness, and I think even
in the largest emerging economies, there is
not only the awareness, but
there's also the conviction that they have
to do things for their own
benefit as well as for the responsibility
they have vis a vie the rest
of the world.